Mel B's estranged husband Stefan  Belafonte breaks his silence following  the America's Got Talent judges shocking  abuse allegations social media posts  painted them as a happy couple in her  new court papers Mel B claims she  discovered that Stefan was having sex  with her nanny  Lauren Gillis got her pregnant and  ordered Loraine to have an abortion and  quote used money earned by me to pay for  it at the time Mel B was a judge on The  X Factor UK you could see the bruises  she now blames on Bellefonte a source  tells ET that mal never told France just  how bad the abuse was but in the docs  she alleges it escalated after he hired  Loraine cephus lawyers tell ET he  eminently denies the claims and that his  focus is on the well-being of his  daughters and stepdaughters Stefan's  attorneys believe this is all a smear  campaign and add quote mr. Belafonte is  confident that the truth will come out